[Música]
economía con luís méndez
louis por supuesto vamos a iniciar este
bloque económico con el conflicto
ruso-ucraniano y la posición de las
naciones occidentales de aumentar las
sanciones a rusia así esa regulación una
posición desde toda la semana
especialmente cuando el presidente job
airén anunció que estaría en europa para
debatir en conjunto con otros líderes
mundiales
esta posibilidad además de la ayuda
militar a la población o en este caso a
ucrania pero uno de los que fue más
enfático en hablar sobre estas sanciones
fue el primer ministro británico boris
johnson quienes anunció que ya vladimir
putin y el presidente ruso había
traspasado o traspasado la línea roja y
por ello había que presionar aún más con
estas sanciones aumentando así la
presión sobre los pagos internacionales
y por qué no apuntar a lo que eran las
reservas de oro y la nación rusa pero
escuchemos qué fue lo que dijo boris
johnson al respecto
pero tienen
creo que la realidad es que vladimir
putin ya cruzó la línea roja y entro en
la barbarie y creo que ahora le
corresponde a la otan considerar juntos
la terrible crisis en ucrania el
terrible sufrimiento del pueblo de
ucrania y ver qué más podemos hacer para
ayudar al pueblo de ucrania a protegerse
ver qué más podemos hacer para apretar
el tornillo económico en torno al
régimen de putin y esas son algunas de
las cosas de las que vamos a hablar
y seguimos hablando de este conflicto
vamos a rusia porque luego el cierre más
largo de la calle desde la calle la
unión soviética abrió parcialmente la
bolsa de moscú list si es raúl ésta
estuvo cerrada desde el pasado 25 de
febrero cuando los activos rusos se
desplomaron en todos los ámbitos tras la
invasión a él a ucrania en este caso la
jornada de este jueves hubo
negociaciones de 33 de las 50 acciones
que cotizan en dicho mercado y la
mayoría ganaron algunos puntos
porcentuales y con ellos disminuyeron
algunas pérdidas pero la nación
intervino para detener una venta masiva
de acciones al tiempo que impuso nuevas
medidas de apoyo entre ellas la
prohibición de venta de acciones y para
los inversores extranjeros impide además
de la venta de acciones la venta de
bonos en rublos hasta el próximo primero
de abril tras la apertura el índice moec
se subió más de cinco puntos
porcentuales durante la tarde local esto
de acuerdo con el medio estadounidense
si en bici hay desconcierto en varios
países asiáticos luego el anuncio a
vladimir putin sobre la venta de gas
ruso a países en amistosos con su nación
y es que muchos de estos países que
están en esa lista de países enemigos de
rusia planteada por esta nación hace
algunas semanas se están viendo
afectados por lo que es el suministro de
casas sin embargo putin ha manifestado
que la decisión tan sólo iría al cambio
de moneda y no a los acuerdos ya
establecidos pero uno de los que habló
sobre esto fue el ministro de finanzas
japonés shinichi suzuki quien señaló que
analizan las situaciones con los
ministerios pertinentes al tiempo que
dijo desconocer
intención rusa tras este planteamiento
japonés uno de los importadores de gas
ruso y de acuerdo con datos de reuters
el año pasado el país recibió el 9 por
ciento de sus importaciones de gas
natural licuado procedentes de rusia
algo similar ocurre en corea del sur el
tercer mayor importador de gas dentro
del mercado asiático donde sus
autoridades anunciaron que están
haciendo lo necesario para facilitar el
comercio y vamos ahora está argentina
luís donde hacemos una recuperación en
el mercado laboral durante el año pasado
2021 esta recuperación se logró gracias
a un crecimiento del producto interno
bruto del país luego de lo que fue la
situación caótica por la pandemia a
pesar de ello la economía aún no
registra los niveles previos a la
recesión iniciada en el año 2018 el pp
de argentina registró en el cuarto
trimestre del año pasado un avance de
1.5 por ciento con relación al tercer
trimestre y una mejora de 8.6 por ciento
en términos interanuales acumulando un
crecimiento de 10.3 por ciento en cuanto
a la tasa de desempleo en el cuarto
trimestre se ubicó en siete puntos
porcentuales esto es decir cuatro puntos
porcentuales del índice registrado en el
mismo periodo del año 2020 y siendo esta
la tasa de desempleo más baja en seis
años bueno así las cosas en materia
económica amós final a nuestro programa
directo américa por el día de hoy luis
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información a ustedes también gracias
por acompañarnos un día más en directo
américa nos vemos en minutos en un
noticiero habitual de france 24 y los
espero
[Música]